good evening I'm Pauline frederick of
NPR moderator of this second of the
historic debates of the 1976 campaign
between Gerald our Ford of Michigan
Republican candidate for president and
Jimmy Carter of Georgia Democratic
candidate for president Thank You
President Ford and Thank You governor
Carter for being with us tonight this
debate takes place before an audience in
the Palace of Fine Arts Theater in San
Francisco an estimated 100 million
Americans are watching on television as
well
San Francisco was the site of the
signing of the United Nations Charter
thirty-one years ago thus it is an
appropriate place to hold this debate
the subject of which is foreign and
defense issues the questioners tonight
are Max Frankel associate editor of The
New York Times
Henry L Truitt diplomatic correspondent
of the Baltimore Sun and Richard
valeriani diplomatic correspondent of
NBC News the ground rules tonight are
basically the same as they were for the
first debate two weeks ago the questions
will be alternated between candidates by
the toss of a coin
governor Carter will take the first
question each questions sequence will be
as follows the question will be asked
and the candidate will have up to three
minutes to answer his opponent will have
up to two minutes to respond and prior
to the response the questioner may ask a
follow-up question to clarify the
candidates answer when necessary with up
to two minutes to reply each candidate
will have three minutes for a closing
statement at the end President Ford and
governor Carter do not have notes or
prepared remarks with them this evening
but they may take notes during the
debate and refer to them mr. Fraenkel
you have the first question for governor
Carter
governor since the Democrats last ran
our foreign policy including many of the
men who are advising you country has
been relieved of the Vietnam agony in
the military draft we've started arms
control negotiations with the Russians
we've opened relations with China we've
arranged the disengagement in the Middle
East we've regained influence with the
Arabs without deserting Israel now maybe
we've even begun a process of peaceful
change in Africa
now you've objected in this campaign to
the style with which much of this was
done and you've mentioned some other
things that that you think ought to have
been done but do you really have a
quarrel with this Republican record
would you not have done any of those
things well I think this Republican
administration has been almost all style
and spectacular and not substance we've
got a chance tonight to talk about first
of all leadership the character of our
country and a vision of the future and
every one of these instances the Ford
administration has failed and I hope
tonight that I am mr. Ford will have a
chance to discuss the reason for those
failures our country is not strong
anymore we're not respected anymore we
can only be strong overseas if we're
strong at home and when I become
president but not only be strong in
those areas but also in defense a
defense capabilities second to none
we've lost in our foreign policy the
character the American people we've
ignored or excluded the American people
into Congress from participation in the
shaping of a foreign policy it's been
one of secrecy and exclusion in addition
to that we've had a chance to become now
contrary to our long-standing beliefs
and principles the arms merchants of the
whole world we've tried to buy success
from our enemies and at the same time
we've excluded from the process the
normal friendship of our allies in
addition to that we've become fearful to
compete with the Soviet Union on equal
pay
we talk about day time the Soviet Union
knows what they want in daytime and
they've been getting it we have not
known what we've wanted and we've been
out traded in almost every instance the
other part I want to make this about our
defense we've got to be a nation blessed
with a defense capability that's
efficient tough capable well organized
nearly focused fighting capability the
ability to fight if necessary is the
best way to avoid the chance fall of the
requirement to fight and the last point
I wanna make is this mr. Ford mr.
Kissinger have continued on with the
policies and failures of Richard Nixon
even the Republican platform has
criticized the lack of leadership in mr.
Ford and they've criticized the foreign
policy of this administration this is
one instance where I agree with with a
Republican platform I might say this in
closing and that is that as far as
foreign policy goes mr. Kissinger has
been the president of his country mr.
Ford has shown an absence of leadership
and an absence of a grasp of what this
country is and what it ought to be
that's got to be changed and that is one
of the major issues in this campaign of
1976 President Ford would you'd like to
respond governor Carter again is talking
in broad generalities let me take just
one question that he raises the military
strength and capability of the United
States governor Carter in November of
1975 indicated that he wanted to cut the
defense budget by 15 billion dollars a
few months later he said he wanted to
cut the defense budget by eight or nine
billion dollars and more recently he
talks about cutting the defense budget
by five to seven billion dollars there
is no way you can be strong militarily
and have those kind of reductions in our
military appropriations now let me just
tell you a little story
about late October of 1975 I asked the
then secretary of defense mr.
Schlesinger to tell me what had to be
done if we were going to reduce the
defense budget by three to five billion
dollars a few days later mr. Schlesinger
came back and said if we cut the defense
budget by three to five billion dollars
we will have to cut military personnel
by 250,000 civilian personnel by a
hundred thousand jobs in America by a
hundred thousand we would have to
stretch out our aircraft procurement we
would have to reduce our naval
construction program we would have to
reduce the research and development for
the army the Navy the Air Force and
Marines by eight percent we would have
to close 20 military bases in the United
States immediately that's the kind of a
defense program that mr. Carter wants
let me tell you this straight from the
shoulder you don't negotiate with mr.
Brezhnev from weakness and the kind of a
defense program that mr. Carter wants
will mean a weaker defense in a poor
negotiating position mr. Truitt a
question for President Ford mr.
president my question really is the
other side of the coin from mr.
Frankel's for a generation the United
States has had a foreign policy based on
containment of communism yet we have
lost the first war in Vietnam we lost a
shoving match in Angola communists
threatened to come to power by peaceful
means in Italy and relations generally
have cooled with the Soviet Union in the
last few months so let me ask you first
what do you do about such cases as Italy
and secondly does this general drift
mean that we're moving back towards
something like an old Cold War
relationship with the Soviet Union I
don't believe we should move to a Cold
War relationship I think it's in the
best interest of the United States and
the world as a whole that the United
States negotiate rather than go back to
the Cold War relationship with the
Soviet Union
I don't look at the picture as Bleakley
as you have indicated in your question
mr. Truitt I believe that the United
States has had many successes in recent
years in recent months as far as the
communist movement is concerned we have
been successful in Portugal where a year
ago it looked like there was a very
great possibility that the Communists
would take over in Portugal it didn't
happen we have a democracy in Portugal
today a few months ago or I should say
maybe two years ago the Soviet Union
looked like they had continued strength
in the Middle East today
according to prime minister Rabine the
Soviet Union is weaker in the Middle
East than they have been in many many
years the facts are there the Soviet
Union relationship with Egypt is at a
low level the Soviet Union relationship
with Syria is at a very low point the
United States today
according to prime minister Rabine of
Israel is at a peak in its influence and
power in the Middle East but let's turn
for a minute to the southern African
operations that are now going on the
United States of America took the
initiative in southern Africa we wanted
to end the bloodshed in southern Africa
we wanted to have the right of
self-determination in southern Africa we
wanted to have majority rule with the
full protection of the rights of the
minority we wanted to preserve human
dignity in southern Africa we have taken
the initiative and in southern Africa
today the United States is trusted by
the black frontline nations and black
Africa the United States is trusted by
the other elements in southern Africa
the United States foreign policy under
this administration has been one of
progress and success and I believe that
instead of talking about Soviet progress
we can talk about
American successes and may I make an
observation part of the question you
asked mr. Truitt I don't believe that
it's in the best interest of the United
States and the NATO nations to have a
communist government in NATO mr. Carter
has indicated he would look with
sympathy to a communist government in
NATO I think that would destroy the
integrity and the strength of NATO and I
am totally opposed to it unfortunately I
just made a statement it's not true I
have never advocated a communist
government for Italy that would
obviously be a ridiculous thing for
anyone to do who wanted to be president
of his country I think that this is a an
instance for a deliberate distortion and
this is occurred also in the question
about defence as a matter of fact I've
never advocated any cut of 15 billion
dollars in our defence budget as a
matter of fact mr. Ford has made a
political football out of the defense
budget about a year ago he cut the
Pentagon budget 6.8 billion dollars
after he fired James Schlesinger the
political heat got so great that he
added back about three billion dollars
when Ronald Reagan won the Texas primary
election mr. Ford added back another one
and a half billion dollars immediately
before the Kansas City convention he
headed back another 1.8 billion dollars
in the defense budget and his own Office
of Management and Budget testified that
he had a three billion dollar cut
insurance added to the defense to budget
defense budget under the pressure from
the Pentagon obviously this is another
indication of trying to use the defense
budget for political purposes which he's
trying to do tonight now we went into
South Africa late after Great Britain
Rhodesia the black nations had been
trying to solve this problem for many
many years we didn't go in until right
before the election
similar to what was taking place in 1972
but mr. Kissinger announced pieces at
hand just before the election at that
time and we have weakened
our position and later because the other
countries in Europe supported the
Democratic forces in Portugal long
before we did we stuck to the Portugal
dictatorships much longer than other
democracies did in this world mr.
bellari on a question for governor
Carter governor Carter much of what the
United States does abroad is done in the
name of the national interest what is
your concept of the national interest
what should the role of the United
States in the world be and in that
connection considering your limited
experience in foreign affairs and the
fact that you take some pride in being a
Washington outsider don't you think it
would be appropriate for you to tell the
American voters before the election the
people that you would like to have in
key positions such as Secretary of State
Secretary of Defense national security
affairs advisor at the White House well
I'm not gonna name my cabinet before I
get elected I got a little place to go
before I start doing that but I have an
adequate background I believe I am a
graduate of the u.s. Naval Academy oath
first military graduate since so eyes
now I've served as governor of Georgia
and have traveled extensively in foreign
countries in South America Central
America Europe the Middle East and in
Japan I've traveled the last 21 months
among the people of this country I've
talked to them and I've listened and
I've seen it firsthand in a very vivid
way the deep hurt has come to this
country in the aftermath of Vietnam and
Cambodia Chile and Pakistan and Angola
and Watergate CIA revelations but we
were formally so proud of the strength
of our country its moral integrity the
representation in foreign affairs of
what our people are what our
Constitution stands for has been gone
and in the secrecy that has surrounded
our foreign policy in the last few years
the American people the Congress have
been excluded I believe I know what this
country ought to be I've been one who's
loved my nation as many Americans do and
I believe that there's no limit placed
on what we can be in the future if we
can harness the tremendous resources
militarily economically and the stature
of our people the meaning of a
constitution in the future every time
we've made a serious mistake in foreign
affairs it's been because the American
people have been excluded from the
process if we can just tell the
intelligence and ability the sound
common sense and a good judgement of the
American people we can once again her a
foreign policy to make us proud instead
of ashamed and I'm not going to exclude
the American people from that process in
the future as mr. forward and kitchen to
have done this is what it takes to have
a sound foreign policy strong at home
strong defense
permanent commitments not betray the
principles of our country and involve
the American people into Congress in the
shaping of a foreign policy every time
mr. Ford speaks from a position of
secrecy in negotiations and secret and
secret treaties that have been pursued
and achieved in supporting dictatorships
in ignoring human rights we are weak and
the rest of the world knows it so these
are the ways that we can restore the
strength of our country and they don't
require a long experience in foreign
policy nobody has that except a
president who served a long time or
Secretary of State but my background my
experience my knowledge of the people of
this country my commitment to our
principles that don't change those are
the best bases to correct the horrible
mistakes of this administration and
restore our own country to a position of
leadership in the world how specifically
governor are you going to bring the
American people into the decision-making
process in foreign policy what does that
mean first of all I would quit
conducting the decision-making process
in secret as has been a characteristic
of mr. Kissinger and mr. Ford in many
instances we've made agreements like in
Vietnam that have been revealed later on
to embarrassment recently on Smith the
president of Rhodesia announced that he
had unequivocal commitments from mr.
Kissinger that he could not reveal the
American people don't know what those
commitments are we've seen in the past
the destruction of elected
like in Chile and the strong support of
military dictatorship there these kinds
of things have hurt us very much I would
restore the concept to the front side
check which was an integral part of the
administration of Franklin Roosevelt and
I would also restore the involvement of
the Congress when Harry Truman was
president he was not afraid to have a
strong Secretary of Defense Dean Acheson
George Marshall was strong secretaries
of a state chisme state but he also made
sure that there was a bipartisan support
the members of Congress author Bannon
Berg Walter George were part of the
process and before our nation made a
secret agreement before we made a
bluffing statement we were sure that we
had to backing not only the President
and Secretary of State but also the
Congress and the people this is a
responsibility of the President and I
think it's very damaging to our country
for mr. Ford to have turned over this
responsibility to the Secretary of State
President Warren do you have a response
Governor Carter again contradicts
himself he complains about secrecy and
yet he is quoted as saying that in the
attempt to find a solution in the middle
east that he would hold unpublicized
meetings with the Soviet Union
I presume for the purpose of imposing a
settlement on Israel and the Arab
nations but let me talk just a minute
about what we've done to avoid secrecy
in the Ford administration after the
United States took the initiative and
working with Israel and with Egypt and
achieving the Sinai to agreement and I'm
proud to say that not a single Egyptian
or Israeli soldier has lost his life
since the signing of the Sinai agreement
but at the time that I submitted the
sinai agreement to the Congress of the
United States I submitted every single
document that was applicable to the
Sinai to agreement it was the most
complete documentation by any president
of any agreement signed by a president
on behalf of the United States
now as far as meeting with the Congress
is concerned during the 24 months that
I've been the president of the United
States
I have averaged better than one meeting
a month with responsible groups or
Committees of the Congress both House
and Senate the Secretary of State has
appeared in the several years that he's
been the secretary before 80 different
committee hearings in the house and in
the Senate the Secretary of State has
made better than 50 speeches all over
the United States explaining American
foreign policy I have made myself at
least 10 speeches in various parts of
the country where I have discussed with
the American people defense and foreign
policy mr. Fraenkel a question for
President Ford this president I'd like
to explore a little more deeply our
relationship with the Russians they used
to brag back in Khrushchev's day that
because of their greater patience and
because of our greed for business deals
that they would sooner or later get the
better of us is it possible that despite
some setbacks in the Middle East they've
proved their point our allies in France
and Italy are now flirting with
communism we've recognized a permanent
communist regime in East Germany we
virtually signed in Helsinki an
agreement that the Russians have
dominance in Eastern Europe we've bailed
out Soviet agriculture with our huge
grain sales we've given them large loans
access to our best technology and if the
Senate hadn't interfered with the
Jackson amendment maybe you would have
given them even larger loans is that
what you call a two-way street of
traffic in Europe I believe that we have
negotiated with the Soviet Union since
I've been president from a position of
strength and let me cite several
examples shortly after I became
president
December of 1974
I met with general secretary Brezhnev in
Vladivostok and we agreed to a mutual
cap on the ballistic missile launchers
at a ceiling of 2,400 which means that
the Soviet Union if that becomes a
permanent agreement we'll have to make a
reduction in their launchers that they
now have or plan to have I negotiated at
Vladivostok with mr. Brezhnev a
limitation on the Mervin of their
ballistic missiles at a figure of 1320
which is the first time that any
president has achieved a cap either on
launchers or on nerves it seems to me
that we can go from there to the grain
sales the grain sales have been a
benefit to American agriculture we have
achieved a 5 and 3/4 year sale of a
minimum of 6 million metric tons which
means that they have already bought
about four million metric tons this year
and are bound to buy another two million
metric tons to take the grain and corn
and wheat that the American farmers have
produced in order to have full
production and these grain sales to the
Soviet Union have helped us tremendously
in meeting the costs of the additional
oil and the oil that we have bought from
overseas if we turn to Helsinki I'm glad
you raised it mr. Franco in the case of
Helsinki 35 nations signed an agreement
including the Secretary of State for the
Vatican
I can't under any circumstances believe
that the His Holiness the Pope would
agree by signing that agreement that the
35 nations have turned over to
the Warsaw Pact nations the domination
of the Eastern Europe it just isn't true
and if mr. Carter alleges that his
holiness by signing that has done it he
is totally inaccurate now what has been
accomplished by the Helsinki agreement
number one we have an agreement where
they notify us and we notify them of any
military maneuvers that are to be
undertaken they have done it in both
cases where they've done so there is no
Soviet domination of Eastern Europe and
there never will be under a Ford
administration I'm sorry I could I just
found it I understand you to say sir
that the Russians are not using Eastern
Europe as their own sphere of influence
and occupying most of the countries
there and and making sure with their
troops that it's a that it's a communist
zone whereas on our side of the line the
Italians and the French are still
flirting with I don't believe mr.
Frankel that the Yugoslavians consider
themselves dominated by the Soviet Union
I don't believe that the Romanians
consider themselves dominated by the
Soviet Union I don't believe that the
poles consider themselves dominated by
the Soviet Union each of those countries
is independent autonomous it has its own
territorial integrity and the United
States does not concede that those
countries are under the domination of
the Soviet Union as a matter of fact I
visited Poland Yugoslavia and Romania to
make certain that the people of those
countries understood that the president
of the United States
and the people of the United States are
dedicated to their independence their
autonomy and their freedom
Governor Carter have you a response well
in the first place I'm not criticizing
his Holiness Pope I was talking about
mr. forward the young fact is that
secrecy has surrounded the decisions
made by the Ford administration in the
case for the Helsinki agreement it may
have been a good agreement at the
beginning but we have failed to enforce
the so-called basket 3-part which
ensures a right of people to migrate to
join the families to be free to speak
out the Soviet Union is still jamming
Radio Free Europe Radio Radio Free
Europe is being jammed we've also seen a
very serious problem with the so-called
Sun and felt document which apparently
mr. Ford has just endorsed which said it
as an organic linkage between the
Eastern European countries in the Soviet
Union and I would like to see mr. Ford
convince the Polish Americans in the
Czech Americans and the Hungarian
Americans in this country that those
countries don't live under the
domination and supervision of the Soviet
Union behind the Iron Curtain we also
have seen mr. Ford exclude himself from
access to the public he hasn't had a
tough cross-examination type press
conference in over 30 days one press
conference he had without sound he's
also shown a weakness in yielding to
pressure the Soviet Union for instance
put pressure on mr. Ford and he refused
to see a symbol of human freedom
recognized around the world Alexander
Solzhenitsyn
the Arabs have put pressure on mr. Ford
and he's yielded and has permitted a
boycott by the Arab countries of
American businesses who trade with
Israel who have American Jews owning or
taking part in the management of
American companies his own Secretary of
Commerce had to be subpoenaed by the
Congress to reveal the names of
businesses who were subject to this
boycott they didn't volunteer the
information he had to be subpoenaed and
the last thing I'd like to say is this
this grain deal with the Soviet Union in
72 was terrible and mr. Ford made up for
it with three embargoes one
to own a life in Japan that's not the
way to run our foreign policy including
international trade mr. Truitt a
question for governor Carter code I'd
like to pick up on that point actually
an on your appeal for a greater measure
of American idealism in foreign affairs
foreign affairs come home to the
American public pretty much in such
issues as oil embargos and grain sales
that sort of thing would you be willing
to to risk an oil embargo in order to
promote human rights in Iran Saudi
Arabia withhold arms from Saudi Arabia
for the same purpose Laura I think you
matter of fact you've perhaps answered
this final part but would you with whole
grain from the Soviet Union in order to
promote civil rights in the and the
Soviet Union
I would never sing loud food as a trade
embargo item if I ever decided to impose
an embargo because of a crisis in
international relationships it would
include all shipments of all equipment
for instance if the Arab countries ever
again declare an embargo against our
nation of oil I would consider that not
a military but an economic declaration
of war and I would respond instantly and
in kind I would not ship that Arab
country anything no weapons no spare
parts for weapons no all drilling rigs
no all pipe no nothing I wouldn't think
about just food another thing I'd like
to say is this in our international
trade as I said in my opening statement
we have become the arms merchants of the
world when this Republican
administration came into office we were
shipping about 1 billion dollars worth
of arms overseas now 10 to 12 billion
dollars worth of arms overseas to
countries who quite often use these
weapons to fight each other the shift in
emphasis has been very disturbing to me
speaking about the Middle East under the
last Democratic administration 60% of
all weapons that went into the Middle
East were for Israel nowadays 75% were
for Israel before now 60%
go to the Arab countries and this does
not include Iran if you include Iran our
present shipment of weapons to the
Middle East only 20%
goes to Israel this is a deviation from
idealism
it's a deviation from a commitment to
our major outline in Middle East which
is Israel
it's a yielding to economic pressure on
the part of the Arabs on the oil issue
and it's also a tremendous indication
that under the foreign administration we
have not addressed the energy policy
adequately we still have no
comprehensive energy policy in this
country and it's an overall sign of
weakness when we're weak at home it
economically high unemployment high
inflation a confused government a
wasteful defense establishment this
encourages the kind of pressure that's
been put on us successfully it would
have been inconceivable 10 15 years ago
for us to be brought to our knees with
an Arab oil embargo but it was done
three years ago and they're still
putting pressure on us from the Arab
countries to our discredit around the
world these are the witnesses that I see
and I believe it's not just a matter of
idealism it's a matter of being tough
it's a matter of being strong it's a
matter of being consistent our
priorities want to be first of all to
meet our own military needs secondly to
meet the needs of our allies and friends
and only then should be shipped military
equipment to foreign countries as a
matter of fact Iran is going to get 80
f-14s before we even meet our own air
force orders for our four teams and the
shipment of Sprint's class destroyers to
Iran a much more highly sophisticated
than the Spruance class destroyers that
are present being delivered to our own
Navy this is ridiculous and it ought to
be changed governor let me pursue that
if I may if I understand you correctly
you would in fact to use my examples
with hold arms from Iran and Saudi
Arabia even if the risk was an oil
embargo and if they should be securing
those arms from somewhere else and then
if the embargo came then you would
respond in kind do I have it correctly
if Iran is not an arab countries you
know there's a muslim country but if
saudi arabia should declare an oil
embargo against us then I would consider
that an economic declaration of war and
I would make sure that the Saudis
understood this ahead of time so there
would be no doubt in their mind
I think under those circumstances they
would refrain from pushing us to our
knees as they did in 1973 with our
previous own embargo president for
governor Carter apparently doesn't
realize that since I've been president
we have sold to the Israelis over four
billion dollars in military hardware we
have made available to the Israelis over
45% of the total economic and military
aid since the establishment of Israel 27
years ago so the Ford administration has
done a good job in helping our good ally
Israel and we're dedicated to the
survival and security of Israel
I believe that governor Carter doesn't
realize the need and necessity for arms
sales to Iran he indicates he would not
make those Iran is bordered very
extensively by the Soviet Union
Iran has Iraq as one of its neighbors
the Soviet Union and the Communist
dominated government of Iraq are
neighbours of Iran and Iran is an ally
of the United States it's my strong
feeling that we ought to sell arms to
Iran for its own national security and
as an ally a strong ally of the United
States the history of our relationship
with Iran goes back to the days of
President Truman when he decided that it
was vitally necessary for our own
security as well as that of Iran that we
should help that country and Iran has
been a good ally in 1973 when there was
an oil embargo Iran did not participate
Iran continued to sell oil to the United
States I believe that it's in our
interest and in the interest of Israel
and Iran and Saudi Arabia for the United
States to sell arms to those countries
it's for their
security as well as ours Lister
valeriani a question for President Ford
mr. president the policy of your
administration is to normalize relations
with mainland China
now that means establishing at some
point full diplomatic relations and
obviously doing something about the
mutual defense treaty with Taiwan if you
are elected will you move to establish
full diplomatic relations with Peking
and will you abrogate the mutual defense
treaty with Taiwan and as a corollary
would you provide mainland China with
military equipment if the Chinese would
ask for our relationship with the
People's Republic of China is based upon
the Shanghai communique of 1972 and that
communique calls for the normalization
of relations between the United States
and the People's Republic it doesn't set
a time schedule it doesn't make a
determination as to how that
relationship should be achieved in
relationship to our current diplomatic
recognition and obligations to the
Taiwanese government the Shanghai
communique does say that the differences
between the People's Republic on the one
hand and Taiwan on the other shall be
settled by peaceful means the net result
is this administration and during my
time as the president for the next four
years we will continue to move for
normalization of relations in the
traditional sense and we will insist
that the disputes between Taiwan and the
People's Republic be settled peacefully
as was agreed in the Shanghai communique
of 1972 the Ford administration will not
let down will not eliminate or forget
our obligation to the people of Taiwan
we feel that there must be a continued
obligation to the people the some 19 or
20 million people in Taiwan and as we
move during the next four years
those will be the policies of this
administration and sir the military
equipment for the mainland Chinese there
is no policy of this government to give
to the People's Republic or to sell to
the People's Republic of China military
equipment I do not believe that we the
United States should sell give or
otherwise transfer military hardware to
the People's Republic of China or any
other communist nation such as the
Soviet Union and the like
governor Carter well I'd like to go back
just one moment to the previous question
where mr. Ford I think confuse the issue
by trying to say that we are shipping
Israel 40% of our aid as a matter of
fact during this current year are we're
shipping Iran or have contracted to ship
to around about seven and a half billion
dollars worth of arms and also to Saudi
Arabia about seven and a half billion
dollars worth of arms also in 1975 we
almost brought Israel to their knees
after the Yom Kippur War by the so
called reassessment of our relationship
to Israel we in effect tried to make
Israel the scapegoat for the problems in
the Middle East and this weakened our
relationship for the Israel a great deal
and put a cloud on the total commitment
that our people feel toward the Israelis
they ought to be a clear unequivocal
commitment without change to Israel in
the 40s I think we need to continue to
be strong and I would certainly pursue
the normalization of relationships with
the People's Republic of China we open
up a great opportunity in 1972 which is
pretty well benefited all right
put read it away under mister forward
that ought to be your constant or
inclination to it to a friendship but I
would never let that friendship with the
People's Republic of China stand in the
way of the preservation of the
independence and freedom of the people
on Taiwan mr. Frankel a question for
governor Carter
govenor we always seem in our elections
and maybe in between to to argue about
who can be tougher in the world give or
take a a few billion dollars give or
take one weapon systems are leading
politicians and I think you two
gentlemen seemed to settle roughly on
the same strategy in the world at
roughly the same Pentagon budget cost
how bad do things have to get in our own
economy or how much backwardness and
hunger would have taken the world to
persuade you that our national security
and our survival required very drastic
cutbacks in armed spending and dramatic
new efforts in other directions well
always in the past we've had an ability
to have a strong defense and also have
to have a strong domestic economy and
also to be strong in our reputation and
influence within the community of
nations these are characteristics of our
country have been endangered under mr.
Ford we are no longer respected in a
showdown vote in the United Nations or
in any other international council we're
lucky to get 20% of the other nations to
vote with us our allies feel that we've
neglected them the so-called Nixon
shocks
against Japan may weaken our
relationships there under this
administration we've also had an
inclination to keep separate the
European countries thinking that if they
are separate then we can dominate them
and proceed with our secret Lone Ranger
type diplomatic efforts I would also
like to point out that we in this
country have let our economy go down a
drain the worst inflation since the
Great Depression the highest
unemployment of any developed nation of
the world we have a higher unemployment
rate in this country than Great Britain
then West Germany our unemployment rate
is twice as high as it is in Italy it's
three or four times as high as it is in
Japan and that
terrible circumstance in this country is
exported overseas we comprise about 30%
of a world's economic trade power
influence and when we wreak at home
weaker than all our allies that weakness
weakens a whole free world so strong
economy is very important another thing
that we need to do is to reestablish the
good relationships that we ought to have
between the United States and our
natural allies and friends they've felt
neglected and using that base of
strength and using the idealism the
honesty the predictability the
commitment the integrity of our own
country that's where our strength lies
and that would permit us to deal with a
developing nations in a position of
strength under this administration we've
had a continuation of the so-called
balance of power politics where
everything is looked on as a struggle
between us on the one side the Soviet
Union on the other our allies the
smaller countries get trampled in the
rush what we need is to try to seek
individualize bilateral relationships
with countries regardless of their signs
and to establish world order politics
which means that we want to preserve
peace through strength we also want to
revert back to the stature and the
respect that our country had in previous
administrations now I can't say when
this can come but I can guarantee you it
will not come if Gerald Ford is
reelected and this present policy has
continued it will come if I'm elected I
hear you right sir you're saying guns
and butter both but President Johnson
also had trouble keeping up both Vietnam
and his domestic programs I was really
asking when do the the needs of the
cities and our own needs and those of
other backward and even more needy
countries and societies around the world
take precedence over some of our
military spending ever well let me say
very quickly that under President
Johnson in spite of the massive
investment in the Vietnam War he turned
over a balanced budget to mr. Nixon the
unemployment rate was less than 4% the
inflation rate under Kennedy and Johnson
was about 2%
one third what it is under this
administration so we did have at that
time with good management the ability to
do both I don't think anybody can say
that Johnson and Kennedy neglected the
poor and the destitute people in this
country or around the world but I can
say this the number one responsibility
of any president above all else is to
guarantee the security of our nation an
ability to be free of the threat of
attack or blackmail and to carry out our
obligations to our allies and friends
and to carry out a legitimate foreign
policy they must go hand in hand but the
security of this nation has got to come
first President Ford let me say very
categorically you cannot maintain the
security and the strength of the United
States with the kind of defense budget
cuts that governor Carter has indicated
in 1975 he wanted to cut the budget 15
billion dollars he's now down to a
figure of five to seven billion dollars
reductions of that kind will not permit
the United States to be strong enough to
deter aggression and maintain the peace
Governor Carter
apparently doesn't know the facts as
soon as I became president I initiated
meetings with the NATO heads of state
and met with them in Brussels to discuss
how we could improve the defense
relationship in Western Europe in
November of 1975 I met with the leaders
of the five industrial nations in France
for the purpose of seeing what we could
do acting together to meet the problems
of the coming recession in Puerto Rico
this year I met with six of the leading
industrial nations heads of state to
meet the problem of inflation so we
would be able to solve it before it got
out of hand
I have met with the heads of government
bilaterally as well as multilaterally
our relations with Japan have never been
better I was the first United States
president to visit Japan and we had the
Emperor of Japan here this past year and
then that result is Japan and the United
States are working more closely together
now that at any time in the history of
our relationship you can go around the
world and let me take Israel for example
just recently president Rabine said that
our relations were never better mr.
Truitt the question for President Ford
mr. president you referred earlier to
your meeting with mr. Brezhnev at
Vladivostok in 1974 at you agreed on
that occasion to try to achieve another
strategic arms limitation salt agreement
within the year nothing happened in 1975
are not very much publicly at least and
those talks are still dragging things
got quieter is the current season
approached is there is there a bit of
politics involved there perhaps on both
sides are perhaps more important our
interim weapons developments and I'm
thinking of such things as the cruise
missile and the Soviet ss-20
intermediate range rocket making salt
irrelevant by passing the salt
negotiations first we have to understand
that salt 1 expires October 3rd 1977 mr.
Brezhnev and I met in Vladivostok in
December of 1974 for the purpose of
trying to take the initial step so we
could have a salt to agreement that
would go to 1985 as I indicated earlier
we did agree on a 2,400 limitation on
launchers of ballistic missiles that
would mean a cutback in the Soviet
program it would not interfere with our
own program at the same time we put a
limitation of 1320 on
our technicians have been working since
that time in Geneva trying to put into
technical language a an agreement that
can be verified by both parties in the
meantime there has developed the problem
of the Soviet backfire their
high-performance aircraft which they say
is not a long-range aircraft in which
some of our people say is a
intercontinental aircraft in the interim
there has been the development on our
part primarily the cruise missiles
cruise missiles that could be launched
from land-based mobile installations
cruise missiles it could be lanced a
launch from high-performance aircraft
like the b-52s or the B ones which I
hope we proceed with cruise missiles
which could be launched from either
surface or submarine naval vessels those
gray area weapon systems are creating
some problems in the agreement for
assault to negotiation but I can say
that I am dedicated to proceeding and I
met just last week with the foreign
minister of the Soviet Union and he
indicated to me that the Soviet Union
was interested in narrowing the
differences and making a realistic and a
sound compromise I hope and trust in the
best interest of both countries and in
the best interest of all people
throughout this globe that the Soviet
Union and the United States can make a
mutually beneficial agreement because if
we do not and salt 1 expires on October
3 1977 you will unleash again
and all-out nuclear arms race with the
potential of a nuclear holocaust of
unbelievable dimensions so it's the
obligation of the president to do just
that and I intend to do so mr. president
let me follow that up by submit that the
cruise missile adds a whole new
dimension to the to the arms competition
and then cite a statement by your office
to the Arms Control Association a few
days ago in which you said that the
cruise missile might eventually be
included in a comprehensive arms
limitation agreement but that in the
meantime it was an essential part of the
American strategic arsenal not may I
assume from that that you're tending to
exclude the cruise missile from the next
salt agreement or is it still negotiable
in that context I believe that the
cruise missiles which we are now
developing in research and development
across the spectrum from air from the
sea or from the land can be included
within a salt ii agreement they are a
new weapon system that has a great
potential both conventional and nuclear
armed at the same time we have to make
certain that the Soviet Union's backfire
which they claim is not an
intercontinental aircraft in which some
of our people contend is must also be
included if we are to get the kind of an
agreement which is in the best interest
of both countries a really believe that
if it's far better for us and for the
Soviet Union and more importantly for
the people around the world that these
two superpowers find an answer for
assault to agreement before October 3
1977 I think good will on both parts
hard bargaining by both parties and a
reasonable compromise will be in the
best interest of all parties Governor
Carter
well mr. Ford acts like he's running for
president for the first time he's been
in office two years and there has been
absolutely no progress made toward a new
salt agreement he has learned the date
of the expiration of salt one apparently
we've seen in this world a development
of a tremendous threat to us as a
nuclear engineer myself I know the
limitations and capabilities of atomic
power i alternate need know that as far
as the human beings on this earth are
concern that the non-proliferation of
atomic weapons is number one only the
last few days with the election
approaching as mr. Ford taken any
interest in a non-proliferation movement
I advocated last May in a speech at the
United Nations that we move immediately
as a nation to declare a complete
moratorium on the testing of all nuclear
devices both weapons and peaceful
devices that we not ship any more atomic
fuel to a country that refuses to comply
with strict control over the wastes
which can be reprocessed
into explosives I've also advocated that
we stop the sale by Germany and France
of resizing plants to Pakistan in Brazil
mr. food hasn't moved on this we also
need to provide an adequate supply of
enriched uranium mr. Ford again under
pressure from the Atomic Energy Lobby
has insisted that this reprocessing or
other Rhian Richmond be done by private
industry and not by the existing or
government plants this kind of confusion
and absence of leadership has led us
drift now for two years with a
constantly increasing threat of atomic
weapons throughout the world we now have
five nations that have atomic bombs that
we know about if we continue under mr.
Ford's policy by 1985 or 90 we'll have
20 nations that have the capability of
exploding atomic weapons this has got to
be stopped that is one of the major
challenges and major undertakings that I
will assume as a next president mr.
valeriani a question for governor Carter
governor Carter earlier tonight you said
America is not strong anymore America is
not respected anymore and I feel I must
ask you do you really believe that the
United States is not the strongest
country in the world do you really
believe that the United States is not
the most respected country in the world
or is that just campaign rhetoric
no it's not just campaign rhetoric I
think that militarily we are strong as
any nation on earth I think we've got to
stay that way and continue to increase
our capabilities to meet any potential
threat but as far as strength derived
from commitment to principles as far as
strength derived from the unity within
our country as far as strength derived
from the people the Congress the
Secretary of State the president sharing
in the evolution and carrying out of a
foreign policy as far as strength
derived from the respect of our own
allies and friends their assurance that
we will be staunch in our commitment
that we will not deviate and they will
give them adequate attention as far as
strength derived from doing what's right
caring for the pool providing food
becoming the breadbasket of the world
instead of the arms merchants of the
world in those respects we're not strong
also will never be strong again overseas
unless we're strong at home and with our
economy and such terrible disarray and
getting worse by the month we've got
500,000 more Americans unemployed today
than we had three months ago we've got
two and a half million more Americans
out of work now then we have mr. Ford
took office this kind of deterioration
in our economic strength is bound to
weaken us around the world and we not
only have problems at home but we export
those problems overseas so as far as the
respect of our own people toward our own
government as far as participation in
the shaping four concepts and
commitments as far as the trust of our
country among the nations of the world
is for us dependence of our country in
meeting the needs and obligations that
we've expressed our allies as far as a
respect of our country even among our
potential adversaries we are weak
potentially we're strong under this
administration that strength has not
been realized
president thorn Governor Carter
brags about the unemployment during
Democratic administrations and condemns
the unemployment at the present time I
must remind him that we're at peace and
during the period that he brags about
unemployment being low the United States
was at war now let me correct one other
comment that Governor Carter has made I
have recommended to the Congress that we
develop the uranium enrichment plant at
Portsmouth Ohio which is a publicly
owned US government facility and have
indicated that the private program which
would follow on in Alabama is one that
may or may not be constructive but I am
committed to the one at Portsmouth Ohio
the governor also talks about morality
in foreign policy the foreign policy of
the United States meets the highest
standards of morality
what is more moral than peace and the
United States is at peace today
what is more moral in foreign policy
than
food conference in Rome in 1974 when the
United States committed six million
metric tons of food over 60% of the food
committed for the disadvantaged and
underdeveloped nations of the world the
forward administration wants to
eradicate hunger and disease in our
underdeveloped countries throughout the
world
what is more moral than for the United
States under the Ford administration to
take the lead in southern Africa in the
Middle East
those are initiatives in foreign policy
which are of the highest moral standard
and that is indicative of the foreign
policy of this country mr. Fraenkel a
question for President Ford mr.
president can we stick with morality
yeah for a lot of people seems to cover
a bunch of sins mr. Nixon and mr.
Kissinger used to tell us that instead
of morality we had to worry in the world
about living with and letting live all
kinds of governments that we really
didn't like North and South Korean
dictator's Chilean fascists Chinese
Communists Iranian emperors and so on
they said the only way to get by in a
wicked world was to treat others on the
basis of how they treated us and not how
they treated their own people but more
recently we seem to have taken a
different tack we've seem to have
decided that it is part of our business
to tell the Rhodesians for instance that
the way they're treating their own black
people is wrong and they've got to
change their government we put pressure
on them we were rather liberal in our
advice to the Italians as to how to vote
is this a new Ford foreign policy in the
making can we expect that you are now
going to turn to South Africa and force
them to change their government to
intervene in similar ways to end the
bloodshed as you called it say in Chile
or Chilean prisons and to throw our
weight around for the for the values
that that we hold dear in the world I
believe that our foreign policy must
press the highest standards of morality
and the initiatives that we took in
southern Africa are the best examples of
what this administration is doing and
will continue to do in the next four
years if the United States had not moved
when we did in southern Africa there's
no doubt there would have been an
acceleration of bloodshed in that tragic
part of the world if we have not taken
our initiative it's very very possible
that the government of Rhodesia would
have been overrun and that the Soviet
Union and the Cubans would have
dominated southern Africa so the United
States seeking to preserve the principle
of self-determination to eliminate the
possibility of bloodshed to protect the
rights of the minority as we insisted
upon the rights of the majority
I believe followed the good conscience
of the American people in foreign policy
and I believe that we have used our
skill Secretary of State Kissinger has
done a superb job in working with the
black African nations of so-called
front-line nations he has done a superb
job in getting the prime minister of
South Africa mr. Forester to agree that
the time had come for a solution to the
problem of Rhodesia secretary Kissinger
in his meeting with Prime Minister Smith
of Rhodesia was able to convince him
that it was in the best interests of
whites as well as blacks in Rhodesia to
find an answer for a transitional
government and then a majority
government this is a perfect example of
the kind of leadership that the United
States under this administration has
taken and I can assure you that this
administration will follow that high
moral principle in our future efforts in
foreign
policy including our efforts in the
Middle East where it is vitally
important because the Middle East is the
crossroads of the world there have been
more disputes and it's an area where
there's more volatility than any other
place in the world but because Arab
nations and the Israelis trust the
United States we were able to take the
lead in the Sinai to agreement and I can
assure you that the United States will
have the leadership role in moving
toward a comprehensive settlement of the
Middle Eastern problems I hope and trust
as soon as possible and we will do it
with the highest moral principles mr.
president just clarify one point there
are lots of majorities in the world that
feel they're being pushed around by
minority governments and are you saying
they can now expect to look to us for
not just good cheer but throwing our
weight on their side in South Africa or
on Taiwan or in Chile to help change
their governments as in Rhodesia I would
hope that as we move to one area of the
world from another and the United States
must not spread itself too thinly that
was one of the problems that helped to
create the circumstances in Vietnam but
as we as a nation find that we are asked
by the various parties either one nation
against another or individual within a
nation that the United States will take
the leadership and try to resolve the
differences let me take South Korea as
an example I have personally told
President PAC that the United States
does not condone the kind of repressive
measures that he has taken in that
country but I think in all fairness and
equity we have to recognize the problem
that South Korea has on the north they
have North Korea with 500
and well-trained well-equipped troops
they are supported by the People's
Republic of China they are supported by
the Soviet Union South Korea faces a
very delicate situation now the United
States in this case this administration
has recommended a year ago and we have
reiterated it again this year that the
United States South Korea North Korea in
the People's Republic of China sit down
at a conference table to resolve the
problems of the Korean Peninsula this is
a leadership role that the United States
under this administration is carrying
out and if we do it and I think the
opportunities and the possibilities are
getting better we will have solved many
of the internal domestic problems that
exist in South Korea at the present time
governor Carter I noticed that mr. Ford
didn't comment on the prisons in Chile
this isn't a typical example maybe of
many others but this administration
overthrew an elected government and
helped to establish a military
dictatorship this has not been an
ancient history story last year on the
Ford of all the food for peace it went
to South America eighty-five percent
went to the military dictatorship in
Chile another point I want to make is
this he says we have to move from one
area of the world to another that's
where the problems with this
administration's so-called shuttle
diplomacy for the Secretary of State's
in one country there are almost 150
others that are wondering what we're
going to do next what will be the next
secret agreement we don't have a
comprehensive understandable foreign
policy that deals with world problems or
even regional problems another thing to
concern me was what mr. Ford said about
unemployment at insinuating that under
Johnson and Kennedy that unemployment
could only be held down when this
country is at war Karl Marx said that
the free enterprise system in a
democracy can only continue to exist
when they are at war or preparing for
war
Karl Marx was a grandfather of communism
I don't agree with that statement I hope
mr. Ford doesn't either he has put
pressure on the Congress and I don't
believe mr. Ford would even deny this to
hold up on non-proliferation legislation
until the Congress agreed for an eight
billion dollar program for private
industry to start producing enriched
uranium and the last thing I want to
make is this he talks about peace and
I'm thankful for peace we were peaceful
but mr. Ford went into office but he and
mr. Kissinger and others tried to start
a new Vietnam in Angola and it was only
the outcry of the American people and
the Congress when their secret deal was
discovered that prevented our renewed
involvement in that configuration which
was taking place there gentlemen I'm
sorry to say we do not have time enough
for two complete sequences of questions
we now have only 12 minutes left
therefore I would like to ask for
shorter questions and shorter answers
and we also will drop the follow-up
question
each candidate may still respond of
course to the others answered mr. Truitt
question for governor Carter Governor
Carter before this event the most
communications I received concerned
Panama is would you as president be
prepared to sign a treaty which at a
fixed date yielded administrative and
economic control of the Canal Zone and
shared defense which as I understand it
is the position the United States took
in 1974 well here again the Panamanian
question is one that's been confused by
mr. Ford he had directed his diplomatic
relations representative to yield to the
Panamanians
full sovereignty over the Panama Canal
Zone at the end of a certain period of
time when mr. Reagan raised this a
question in floor
mr. food not only disavowed his
instructions but he also even dropped
parenthetically the use of the word
daytime I would never give up complete
control or practical control of the
Panama Canal tone but I would continue
to negotiate with the Panamanians when
the original treaty was signed back in
the early 1900s when Theodore rose was
president Panama retained sovereignty
over the Panama Canal Zone we retain
control as though we had sovereignty now
I would be willing to go ahead with
negotiations I believe that we could
share more fully responsibilities for
the Panama Canal Zone with Panama I
would be willing to continue to raise
the payment for shipment of goods
through the Panama Canal Zone
I might even be willing to reduce to
some degree our military emplacements in
the Panama Canal Zone but I would not
relinquish practical control of the
Panama Canal Zone in determine the
foreseeable future president thorn the
United States must and will maintain
complete access to the Panama Canal the
United States must maintain a defense
capability of the Panama Canal and the
United States will maintain our national
security interest in the Panama Canal
the negotiations for the Panama Canal
started under President Johnson and have
continued up to the present time
I believe those negotiations should
continue but there are certain
guidelines that must be followed and
I've just defined let me take just a
minute to comment on something that
governor Carter said on non-new
nonproliferation in May of 1975 I call
for a conference of Nuclear Suppliers
that conference has met six times in May
of this year Governor Carter took the
first initiative approximately 12 months
after I had taken my initiative a year
ago
mr. valeriani a question for a president
for mr. president the Government
Accounting Office has just put out a
report suggesting that you shot from the
hip and the mayagüez rescue mission and
that you ignored diplomatic messages
saying that a peaceful solution was in
prospect why didn't you do more
diplomatically at the time and a related
question did the White House try to
prevent the release of that report the
White House did not prevent the release
of that report on July 12th of this year
we gave full permission for the release
of that report I was very disappointed
in the fact that the GAO released that
report because I think it interjected
political partisan politics at the
present time but let me comment on the
report somebody who sits in Washington
DC 18 months after the mayagüez incident
can be a very good grandstand
quarterback and let me make another
observation this morning I got a call
from the skipper of the mayagüez he was
furious because he told me that it was
the action of me President Ford that
saved the lives of the crew of the
mayagüez and I can assure you that if we
have not taken the strong and forceful
action that we did we would have been
criticized very very severely for
sitting back and not moving captain
Miller is thankful the crew is thankful
we did the right thing it seems to me
that those who sit in Washington 18
months after the incident are not the
best judges of the decision-making
process that had to be made by the
National Security Council and by myself
at the time the incident was developing
in the Pacific let me assure you that we
made every possible overture to the
People's Republic of China and through
them to the Cambodian government we made
diplomatic protests to the Cambodian
government through the United Nations
every possible diplomatic means was
utilized but at the same time I had a
responsibility and so did the National
Security Council to meet the problem at
hand and we handled it responsibly and I
think captain Miller's testimony to that
effect is the best evidence Governor
Carter
well I'm reluctant II will comment on
the recent report I haven't read it I
think the American people have only one
requirement that the facts about Merguez
be given to them accurately and
completely
mr. Ford has been there for 18 months he
had the fact that we release today
immediately after the Merguez incident I
understand that the report today is
accurate mr. Ford has said I believed
that it was accurate and that the White
House made no attempt to block the
issuing of that report I don't know if
that's exactly accurate or not I
understand that both the Secretary of
Department of State and the Defense
Department have approved the accuracy of
today's report on yesterday's report and
also the National Security Agency I
don't know what was right of what was
wrong of what was done the only thing I
believe is that whatever their knowledge
was mr. Ford had should have been given
to the American people 18 months ago
immediately after my crash so incident
occurred this is what the American
people want when something happens that
endangers our security or when something
happens it threatens our stature in the
world or when American people are
endangered by the actions of a foreign
country just 40 sailors on the Marg
where's we obviously have to move
aggressively and quickly to rescue them
but then after the immediate action is
taken I believe the president has an
obligation to tell the American people
the truth and not wait 18 months later
for the report to be issue gentlemen at
this time we have time for only two very
short questions mr. Fraenkel a question
for governor Carter
governor Carter if the price of gaining
influence among the Arabs is closing our
eyes a little bit to their boycott
against Israel how would you handle that
I believe that they boycotted
of American businesses by the Arab
countries because those businesses trade
with Israel because they have American
Jews who are owners or directors in the
company is an absolute disgrace this is
the first time that I remember in the
history of our country when we've got a
foreign country circumvent or change our
Bill of Rights
I'll do everything I can as president to
stop the boycott of American businesses
by the Arab countries it's not a matter
of diplomacy or trade with me it's a
matter of morality and I don't believe
that there are countries will pursue it
when we have a strong president who will
protect the integrity of our country the
commitment of our Constitution and Bill
of Rights and protect people in this
country who happen to be Jews it may
later be Catholics it may be it later be
Baptist who are threatened by some
foreign country but we ought to stand
staunch and I think it's a disgrace that
so far mr. Ford's administration has
blocked the passage of legislation they
would have revealed by law every
instance of the boycott and it would
have prevented the boycott from
continuing President Ford again governor
Carter is in Akron the Arab boycott
action was first taken in 1952 and in
November of 1975 I was the first
president to order the executive branch
to take action affirmative action
through the Department of Commerce and
other cabinet departments to make
certain that no American businessman or
business organization should
discriminate against Jews because of an
Arab boycott and I might add that my
administration and I'm very proud of it
is the first administration that has
taken an antitrust action against
but he's in this country that have
allegedly cooperated with the Arab
boycott
just on Monday of this week I signed a
tax bill that included an amendment that
would prevent companies in the United
States from taking a tax deduction if
they have in any way whatsoever
cooperated with the Arab boycott and
last week when we were trying to get the
export administration act through the
Congress necessary legislation my
administration went to Capitol Hill and
tried to convince the House and the
Senate that we should have an amendment
on that legislation which would take
strong and effective action against
those who participate or cooperate with
the Arab boycott
one other point because the Congress
failed to act I am going to announce
tomorrow that the Department of Commerce
will disclose those companies that have
participated in the Arab boycott this is
something that we can do the Congress
failed to do it and we intend to do it
mr. Truitt a very brief question for
President Ford mr. president if you get
the accounting of missing-in-action you
want from North Vietnam or from Vietnam
I'm sorry now would you then be prepared
to reopen negotiations for restoration
of relations with that country let me
restate our policy as long as Vietnam
North Vietnam does not give us a full
and complete accounting of our missing
in action I will never go along with the
admission of Vietnam to the United
Nations if they do give us a bonafide
complete accounting of the 800m IAS then
I believe that the United States should
begin negotiations for the admission of
Vietnam to the United Nations but not
until they have given us the full occur
of our Mis Governor Carter one of the
most embarrassing failures at the port
administration and one that touches
specifically on human rights is his
refusal to a point a Presidential
Commission to go to Vietnam to go to
Laos to go to Cambodia and try to trade
for the release of information about
those who are missing in action in those
Wars this is what the families of mas
want so far mr. Ford has not done it
we've had several fragmentary efforts by
members of the Congress and Bryan by
private citizens several months ago the
Vietnam government said we are ready to
sit down and negotiate for a lease of
information on in my age so far mr. Ford
has not responded I also would never
normalize relationships with Vietnam nor
permit them to join the United Nations
until they've taken this action but
that's not enough we need to have an
active and aggressive action on part of
the president leader of this country to
seek out every possible way to get that
information which has kept the m.i.a
families in despair and doubt and mr.
Ford has just not done it Thank You
governor Carter that completes the
questioning for this evening
each candidate now has up to three
minutes for a closing statement it was
determined by the toss of a coin that
governor Carter would take the first
question and he now goes first with his
closing remarks governor Carter
the purpose of this debate and the
outcome of the election will determine
three basic things leadership upholding
the principles of our country and proper
priorities and commitments for the
future this election will also determine
what kind of world we leave our children
will it be a nightmare world threatened
with the proliferation of atomic bombs
not just in five major countries but
dozens of smaller countries that have
been permitted to develop atomic weapons
because of a failure of our top
leadership to stop proliferation will we
have a world of hunger and hatred and
will we be living in an armed camp
stripped of our friendship and allies
hiding behind a tight defense that's
been drawn in around us because we're
fearful of the outside world will we
have a government of secrecy that
excludes the American people from
participation in making basic decisions
and therefore covers up mistakes and
makes it possible for our government our
government to depart from the principles
of our Constitution the Bill of Rights
or will we have a world of peace with
the threat of atomic weapons eliminated
with full trade with our people at work
inflation control openness in government
our people proud once again Congress
citizens president Secretary of State
working in harmony and unity toward a
common future a world where people have
enough to eat and a world where we care
about those who don't can we become a
breadbasket of the world instead of the
arms merchants of the world I believe we
can and we ought to now we've been hurt
in recent years in this country
in the aftermath of Vietnam Cambodia
Chile Pakistan Angola Watergate CIA
we've been hurt our people feel that
we've lost something precious that's not
necessary I want to see our nation risk
return to a posture an image and a
standard to make us proud once again I
remember the world of NATO and the world
of 0.4 and the world of the Marshall
Plan and the world of the Peace Corps
bucket we have that once again we ought
to be a beacon for nations who search
for peace and who search for freedom who
search for individual liberty who search
for basic human rights
we haven't been lately we can be once
again we'll never have that world
leadership until we are strong at home
and we can have that strength if we
return to the basic principles it don't
have to be a strength of bombast and
threats there ought to be a quiet
strength based on the integrity of our
people the vision of the Constitution
and in a strong will and purpose that
God's given us in the greatest nation on
earth
business force as we have seen tonight
foreign policy and defense policy are
difficult and complex issues we can
debate methods we can debate one
decision or another but there are two
things which cannot be debated
experience and results in the last two
years I have made policy decisions
involving long range difficulties and
policies and made day-to-day judgments
not only as president of the United
States but as the leader of the free
world
what is the result of that leadership
America is strong America is free
America is respected not a single young
American today is fighting or dying on
any foreign battlefield America is at
peace with freedom thank you and good
time
Thank You President Ford Thank You
governor Carter I also want to thank our
questioners and the audience here this
evening the third and final debate
between President Ford and governor
Carter will take place on October the
22nd at 9:30 p.m. Eastern Daylight Time
on the campus of the College of William
and Mary in Williamsburg Virginia the
subject matter would cover all issues
these debates are sponsored by the
League of Women Voters education fund to
help voters become better informed on
the issues and to generate greater voter
turnout in the November election now
from the Palace of Fine Arts Theatre in
San Francisco good night